you
we humble residents of Earth are all too
familiar with destructive weather
tornadoes hurricanes hail the size of
golf balls even bizarre phenomena like
fire tornadoes but compared to much of
the universe we've got it pretty easy in
this video we're going to go on a field
trip to some of the most amazing and
terrifying places in the universe where
death isn't just a possibility it's the
rule let's check out the best places in
the universe to die a horrible death
the first stop on our journey is the
tiny brown dwarf star lumen 16 B of
course size is relative on a cosmic
scale the small star is about the same
size as Jupiter though with considerably
more mass lumen 16 B is located just 6.5
light-years from our own Sun making it
the most convenient location on our list
with our current technology it would
only take us about a hundred fifty
thousand years to get there brown dwarf
stars like lumen 16 B are interesting
because they're not hot enough to burn
with the intensity of a larger star like
our Sun that means they can develop
weather patterns similar to those found
on gas giants like Jupiter for this
thought experiment we're going to assume
we have some technology that allows us
to land on the surface or hover in the
atmosphere of our destinations as we
descend through the patchy clouds of
lumen 16 B will realize that this
hellscape is a metal bands dream
location for an album cover the
temperature reaches a searing 2,000
degrees Celsius and those clouds we pass
through don't shower the star with rain
but rather with molten iron so if death
by white-hot metal rain is your thing
lumen 16 B is the ideal vacation spot
for you our next location is a bit of a
trek sitting a whopping 489 light-years
from Earth at first glance the exoplanet
Corot 7b seems like a decent spot to
establish a human colony it's rocky
about five times the mass of Earth and
just shy of twice the size there are
just a couple tiny problems first and
foremost due to its proximity to its
parent star Corot 7b is probably covered
almost entirely with lava this discovery
prompted the creation of a new category
of exoplanets given the terrifying name
lava ocean planets this hellish world is
tidally locked to its star meaning one
side is permanently facing the star and
the other is facing away that means that
the light side of the planet can reach
temperatures up to 2200 degrees Celsius
while the dark side can plunge as low as
minus 210 to make things worse the
temperature on the bright side is so
intense it can vaporize Rock when this
rock vapor is drawn up into the
atmosphere it condenses back into solid
form and helps the surface with blazing
hot stones if that's still not
inhospitable enough for you kuroh 7b is
regarded to be one of the most
volcanically active exoplanets yet
discovered gravitational tugs from one
of its two sister planets caused rampant
volcanism that far exceeds that of
Jupiter's moon Io
which is riddled with over 400 active
volcanoes so if lumen 16b was too tame
for you consider making Corot 7b your
brutal death of choice the third stop on
our list is probably just upset we gave
it the obnoxiously long name HD 189 733
be for the sake of brevity
it'll be known as HD 18 for the rest of
this video HD 18 is located about 63
light-years away in the constellation
vulpecula a weary traveler could be
forgiven for thinking they had made it
to earth as the planet is a friendly
cobalt blue unfortunately for said
traveler it would be the last mistake
they ever made the weather on HD 18 is
incredible and deadly the temperature on
this tidally locked gas giant can reach
upwards of 1,000 degrees Celsius
not as scorching as our previous
destinations but still hot enough to
kill just about anything the wind whips
around the planet at a rate of 2 km/s or
7 times the speed of sound the brave
among us might say so what it's a little
breezy that perpetual super wind is
dangerous enough on its own but it's
what makes the planet blue that's the
real danger while earth gets its
signature blue look from reflected light
from its oceans HD 18 is blue because
its atmosphere consists largely of
superheated silicate particles as we
learn from Kuro 7b strange particles in
the atmosphere can lead to some exotic
forms of rain and HD 18 is a perfect
example of just how absurd it can get
carry it around the planet at 2
kilometers per second is a raging vortex
of glass shards when the silicate
particles condense and fall towards the
surface the fearsome winds carry the
shards of glass with it
creating a perpetual planetary whirlwind
of razor blades landing on HD 18 is the
way to go if you'd like to be instantly
shred
two pieces on a very pretty blue planet
as we near the end of our trip we find
our fourth destination HD 806 o6b
hereafter referred to as HD 806 this
particular exoplanet has a very hard
existence located about 200 light-years
from Earth
HD 806 has the second most eccentric
orbit of any planet yet discovered this
gas giant spends most of it's 111 day
orbit at a distance from its star that
would place it between Earth and Venus
in our solar system
but over a period of about 6 hours when
it's closest to its star HD 806
experiences a temperature spike from
around 500 Celsius all the way up to
1,200 degrees Celsius this extreme spike
in temperature essentially causes the
atmosphere to ignite triggering a
massive explosion every 111 days the
shockwave generated from this explosion
causes massive planet-wide storms and
wind speeds reaching 5 km/s more than
twice the speed of the glass storm
raging on HD 18:00 if you were present
above the clouds of HD 806 during its 6
our ignition period you would see its
star filling more and more of the sky
increasing in brightness by almost a
factor of 1,000 then if you could
somehow survive the increasing heat
you'd be subjected to tremendous force
and pressure from the shockwave you'd go
out with a bang no list of terrifying
space phenomena would be complete
without the ever-popular black hole
specifically we're going to visit the
supermassive black hole contained within
the hyper luminous quasar s500 one for
+81 hereafter referred to as s5 for
almost 60 years scientists thought the
black hole contained within the m87
system was the largest in existence and
it is massive at 6.5 billion times the
mass of our Sun but it's tiny compared
to s5 the s5 black hole has a mass of 40
billion times that of our Sun this
behemoth has an external horizon of 236
point seven billion kilometers over 37
times the diameter of Pluto's orbit
besides being incomprehensibly huge s5
is also incredibly ancient it's thought
to have formed just 1.6 billion years
after the beginning of the universe
black holes are an incredibly complex
aspect of our natural universe and
there's still much speculation about
exactly what
happens far past their event horizon so
if a mysterious death by
spaghettification inside one of the most
ancient and massive destructive forces
in the universe
sounds like the ideal way to go the s5
black hole is a must visit and that
wraps up our little tour of some of the
most ridiculous places to die in the
universe hopefully you found one that
fits the bill and who knows with the
James Webb telescope nearing launch
there might be even more absurdly
terrifying locations just waiting to be
found if you'd like to learn more about
any of the places mentioned in this
video check out the links in the
description make sure to subscribe if
you haven't already follow second
thought on your favorite social media
and leave a comment down below with your
favorite location from the list or one
that wasn't mentioned you can watch my
other space related videos by clicking
here or watch all my videos by clicking
here thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next video